twitter is announcing a new policy to
censor
anyone who publishes conspiracy theories
about anything
but specifically right now anyone who
publishes conspiracy theories
about the coronavirus or the coronavirus
vaccine
obviously of course this is a wonderful
thing
because there is no reason in the world
to be skeptical of the vaccine
which just happened to have been made in
record time
by lots of experts who squandered all
their credibility back in march there's
no reason
to be concerned at all by the way the
vaccine is already being given to health
care workers
like for instance this lovely nurse in
tennessee
who took the vaccine and then was
interviewed on television take a listen
to why there's nothing to worry about we
are
in the covered unit so therefore you
know my team will
be getting first chances to get vaccine
and i know that um it's
really i'm sorry i'm feeling really
dizzy
oh i'm sorry
and she is
on the ground probably just a
coincidence
uh nothing nothing that she's completely
out cold uh nothing to see here
obviously this how dare you suggest
that this has anything to do with the
vaccine do not post that video on
twitter
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday
is from cultural cachistocracy
who says 2020 turned alex jones
from conspiracy theorist to profit i had
to say
the year has been pretty wild and one
thing regardless you know putting aside
other things alex jones has said in his
life
i always gave him credit because he's
right about the frogs
you know there's that clip where he says
they're turning the freaking frogs gay
and everyone would make fun of him for
this and it turns out of all the things
alex jones ever said
that one might be the most correct there
was a study it was undertaken by the epa
and yale
in connecticut that these chemicals in
the water were actually they weren't
just turning the frogs gay they were
turning them
hermaphroditic so they were they were
transiting the frogs if anything alex
jones was
too modest in his reporting
on what they were doing to the frogs
some of the other things i think a
little less credible
but certainly on the frogs he uh he
totally got it who knows it's very
difficult to see things clearly
in 2020 it's been such a strange year if
you want to see clearly though for a
really great price i would go to
coastal.com
at coastal.com you can get prescription
glasses starting at nine dollars
with free shipping and 30 day risk-free
returns plus
they have the most advanced virtual try
on technology that you will find
anywhere i was totally blown away by
this
you go on the website you can look at it
on your phone too and you see the
glasses on you
but it's not just like a picture
floating you can turn your head you can
see how it looks when the glasses turn
it's really really great stuff
you can turn your frames into sunglasses
by testing out colored lens tints
or finally see what a cat eye or aviator
would really look like on your face
right on your phone sometimes you wonder
could i really pull this off i don't
know i get a little
i get a little flamboyant when it comes
to my sunglasses maybe
maybe you can too coastal has over 2000
frames
to choose from and 24 hour customer
support
we are talking about newsweek's uh
america's best
customer service that's what they called
it use your fsa benefits
now before they run out now and for a
limited time they are offering our
listeners
the best deal that they have going
anywhere 50
off your first pair of glasses at
coastal.com michael get free shipping 30
day risk free returns
and 50 5-0 percent off at coastal.com
michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l com slash michael
some restrictions may apply
i don't think i'm gonna get that vaccine
it's not because i am against vaccines
per se
it's not because i think that this
vaccine
is necessarily bad in and of itself i'm
just
taking a little bit of a risk
calculation here
i am healthy i am young
my risk statistically from this virus is
extraordinarily low
and so i'm probably not going to take it
i don't have hard evidence
other than that poor lady passing out in
tennessee
she turns out she's fine she's fine now
but she did pass out from it
i i don't have any you know particular
evidence that the
vaccine is evil or it's going to kill me
or it's going to have serious side
effects
but i don't really see the upside either
and i think a lot of people are going to
be making that
that calculation prudence so this is
this is a virtue we've been talking
about a lot
on this show the past week or two
conservatives you know we understand
that there's risk in everything in the
world and we're going to use our common
sense
and common sense is lacking in a lot of
rationalist political ideologies
but we should keep exercising it as for
that nurse by the way
after she talk about the worst pr
moment ever that you could have for this
vaccine
people are already pretty skeptical of
it because the experts got everything
wrong this year and because vaccines
take years if not decades to develop
and we got this vaccine in like six
months so
she goes out she goes oh yeah it's great
you know it's cool i got this vaccine
my whole team's gonna get it and whoa
i'm feeling a little woozy her excuse is
that she passes out whenever she feels
pain and she says it's common for me
now i i don't know that i necessarily
believe this
first of all because it's not like she
was getting the vaccine in that moment
it's not like the needle was going into
her in that moment she feels the pain
and she passes out she clearly already
had it
earlier and then all of a sudden decided
to feigned
or you know was was overcome by this
this uh fainting
also if if this nurse knew that she had
this condition
where when she gets a shot she feigns
why would they pick her to hold the
press conference about how great the
vaccine is
that seems at least incompetent
and if the healthcare apparatus is that
incompetent
i'm a little skeptical of them which i
think i think a lot of us are
speaking of remaining uh
healthy and skeptical keeping a healthy
skepticism
of all of these sorts of expert claims
there's a new study published in
the physics of fluids scientific journal
man they have a magazine for everything
don't they
the physics of fluids journal shows that
wearing a used mask
is potentially riskier than wearing no
mask
at all if only if only a certain
scientific expert had mentioned this
at the very beginning of this epidemic
as i have done on this show
as much as i possibly can
look i'm citing this study because this
study backs up
the point that i'm making i don't really
care about any of the studies
because my argument against the masks is
not scientific
my argument against the masks is
political because the masks are a
political symbol they are not primarily
a scientific or medical instrument at
the beginning of the epidemic dr fauci
who's been in his job for 50 years
said the masks are stupid during this
sort of pandemic don't wear the masks
he said they'll make people feel a
little bit better but they don't do
anything medically
then he comes out five seconds later he
says oh yeah never mind forget about
that pay no attention on the man behind
the curtain yeah
wear the masks they're really important
you gotta wear the masks all the time
and i thought
no this this is a highly politicized
instrument now
whatever the medical effect of it maybe
it has some medical effect maybe it
doesn't
obviously the change in in his tune is a
political change in tune
but beyond that that was just assuming
you're always wearing a clean mask
and part of fouchy's original point
before he contradicted himself was
even when you're putting a clean mask on
you're touching your face you're near
your mouth
you know it's you're not wearing it
correctly gives you a full sense of
security
so don't do it it can actually be
harmful now add on top of that
the reality of how people wear these
masks which is
they don't wash them every time they
wear them they don't replace them every
time they wear them
what do you do you take you have the
mask and you put it in your pocket
and you usually don't wear it and then
you got to go pick up take out or
something
you got to go into the grocery store and
so you put the take it out of your
pocket or your purse where you put it on
your face
you probably haven't watched the thing
in a week more than a week probably if
you're a guy
you probably haven't watched the thing
ever since march or so right
obviously that mask is going to be
carrying more germs and if you're just
breathing in
the fresh air like a normal person
this study if you want to look it up
comes from university of massachusetts
lowell
and california baptist university shows
that the three-layer surgical mask
is 65 efficient in filtering particles
in the air
however once it's used that
effectiveness falls to 25
and then when it's used for a very long
time and grows all sorts of bacteria
that is not a very good situation
we still hear many conservatives
deferring
to this liberal idea
that we should follow the science
and follow the science is another slogan
that means the same thing as
let's put politics aside for a second
you ever hear that usually you'll hear
the same people who say follow the signs
and say look this isn't political
let's put the politics aside and as my
friend nan hayworth points out
whenever someone tells you let's put the
politics aside get ready to have your
politics on deck
because there is no more political
statement in the world than let's put
politics aside because what
what people are saying what they mean
when they say that is
my political opinion is so
necessary to society that it should be
beyond the realm of debate
what they're really saying is put your
politics aside and listen to me
i'm going to define my politics as
science and then
because it's science it's irrefutable
and you have to do exactly what i tell
you to do
science is not
an exception to politics in public life
the whole the whole point of this that
there's some aspect of public life
that's totally outside of politics
it's just not true even science even the
most
hard-nosed scientist will bend the knee
to the social and political standards of
his time
you see this clearly in the past few
days in the new england
journal of medicine new england journal
of medicine just posts this yesterday to
the internet
quote sex designations on birth
certificates offer
no clinical utility and they can be
harmful for intersex
it's like hermaphrodites people where
their genitals are sort of ambiguous
and transgender transgender you know
when a man thinks he's a woman or vice
versa
people moving such designations below
the line of demarcation would not
compromise the birth certificate's
public health function
but could avoid harm and they posted
this this line from some of the mds
on on from the new england journal
medicine we believe that it is now time
to update the practice of designating
sex on birth certificates
meaning that a very very prominent
medical
scientific journal
is throwing biology aside and
acquiescing to gender theory gender
theory
a very very novel political ideology
that has only come into the mainstream
really in the last 20 years if that
it sort of started bubbling up in 60s
really
but only in the last 20 years has it
entered the mainstream
science already acquiesces but it's the
science this is
actually why i sort of i don't usually
use the the typical conservative
arguments against
transgenderism typical conservative
arguments is look at the chromosomes you
know men have a y chromosome and women
have two x chromosomes and that's just a
scientific fact
i sort of think when we invoke science
you know as this thing outside of
politics we're actually kind of giving
the left an important premise here
because the the left because the left
owns the established institutions
they will use science
to pervert itself and to back up their
political claims
science now is totally embracing gender
ideology expect more
scientific journals to follow what are
what are our arguments against this
what's the
strong conservative argument i mean you
can mention the chromosome sure that's
fine you can mention
genitals that's fine you can mention
physical reality but i think what we
need to do is call out the philosophical
basis of these things for instance the
gender ideology rests on
an ancient religious heresy it's called
gnostic
dualism the idea that your true self has
nothing to do
with your physical body this is a heresy
from the early
you know third century fourth century
and fifth century it really thrived
then it came back again in the 11th
century and sort of the middle ages with
the albigensian heresy now it's come
back again with gender theory
it's hard you know there there is a
basis on which all of these sorts of
things
rely and that either you're going to
have
the traditional standards or you're
going to have the politically correct
standards but you will have standards
and it's not just in science it's
corporate america too
conservatives have made a big mistake
over the past 30 or so years which is
that
we've we've actually shrunk the realm of
politics we've done what the left has
suggested we do where everything becomes
political except for politics which gets
exported to a group of experts who run
our lives for us
and we've said okay the government can
the only threat that we ever have is
from the government
corporate americans can do whatever they
want the scientific establishment can do
whatever they want
big tech can do whatever they want and
guess what
if my rights are being restricted if my
traditions are being destroyed if my
country is being hollowed out
by corporate america or or
big tech or some scientific
establishment
i don't feel any better than if it were
all being hollowed out by the government
and i think we need to take a broader
view of politics here
you now have the ceo of one of the most
prominent and influential
financial firms in the world now telling
corporate america
if they don't get woke if they don't go
along with leftist politics
they're going to be destroyed it's going
to hit their bottom line
this is a time to protect not just
our institutions not just our culture
but also ourselves
and one great way to do that is with
axon
tasers line of non-lethal
self-protection devices they are small
they're lightweight enough to carry with
you
or to put in your glove compartment or
purse they're also powerful enough
to incapacitate an attacker what they do
is they use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds
and this is the civilian issue one by
the way the civilian issue one actually
gives you
longer time than the the police issue
one because
you know usually the cops have other
kinds of tools at their disposal they're
a little more trained
with the civilian taser you just shoot
it 30 seconds gives you time to escape
to safety and send emergency dispatch to
your gps location
this is connected with bluetooth so
you'll call right to
911 and you'll get that emergency help
they also have laser assisted targeting
you can protect yourself and your family
with taser's line of smart
self-defense products this is a terrific
product one great thing it's available
without a permit in most u.s states
get the taser pulse plus or taser strike
light at taser.com with promo code
knowles kwles
say 15 now at taser.com promo code
knowles t-a-s-e-r
dot com promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s
restrictions apply sea site for details
blackrock's chairman big big financial
firm larry fink
says quote in 2020
we identified 244 companies that were
making insufficient
progress integrating climate risk
into their businesses into their
business models or disclosures
of these companies we took voting action
against 53
or 22 we've put the remaining 191
companies
on watch those that do not make
significant progress
risk voting action against management in
2021
if you don't get on the environmentalist
agenda which from from the beginning
in the united states was a sort of
incoherent scientific patina
that was put over goals that the
political left has had for 100 years
if you don't get on board with that
you're going to have your ceo voted out
you're going to have your company hit
by extraordinarily influential financial
firms
just a little reminder of the
environmentalist movement
we were told in the late 1960s and early
70s that overpopulation was a serious
problem
and that there would it was inevitable
that we would have mass starvation
famines deaths
within 10 to 20 years it was paul
ehrlich a
stanford scientist who who told us this
a
very famous book the population bomb and
so he said we need a lot of abortion we
need a lot of contraception
we need to stop having kids and if
people don't do that voluntarily maybe
we're going to need to coerce people to
do that that turned out to be complete
bunk it was a hundred percent false
that guy was could not have been more
wrong
but because he was backing up the
left-wing political agenda he's never
faced any consequences he
was able to continue teaching at
stanford he continued to receive
extraordinarily prestigious prizes
even though the central thesis of this
dude's whole career a horrific thesis
that caused untold misery it led to in
many ways the one child policy in china
it led to uh sterilization horrific
uh abuses by the left-wing government in
india
abortion that sort of thing uh this guy
never faced any consequences because he
went with the left-wing agenda then in
the 1970s you had global cooling
you had not just newspapers but
significant scientific
uh institutions describing global
cooling in the 1970s so what do we got
to do
we need to give the government more
power we need to stop moving we need to
stop reproducing we need to stop all the
things the left wants
then it turns out global cooling didn't
happen then we had global warming okay
what do we need to do for that
the exact same thing all this the same
exact left-wing agenda that's what we
need
then the warming stopped for okay well
now we need it's climate change
so i don't know it's something's gonna
happen you know if if the sun's shining
one day and it's raining the next
you've got to stop having kids and you
need to give the government more control
over your stuff
and you need to pay more taxes and you
need to stop
living your life it's always the same
agenda it's not the same reasoning
often it's opposite reasoning but it's
always the same agenda and that's what
the black rock he's saying look
we're not saying you got to be political
you just got to get on board with the
scientific environmentalism and if you
don't by the way
and if you don't get on board with that
agenda which happens to coincide exactly
with what the left has wanted since the
early 20th century at least we're going
to destroy
your company a coherent
conservative movement needs to stop that
a coherent conservative movement needs
to stop giving technocrats and lab coats
the authority to run our lives a
coherent
conservative movement needs to assert
its political freedom
trump did a good job at exposing this
he continues to do a good job at
exposing this
that's why they hate trump but they
don't just hate trump
that is the biggest lie of the trump era
it's a bigger lie than the russia hoax
or the ukraine hoax or what any of those
things
the biggest lie of the trump era is that
the left has some special hatred for
donald trump
they actually kind of like donald trump
remember donald trump was
in their clubs and in their parties for
decades
he was hollywood royalty a top network
tv star
hillary clinton and bill clinton came to
his wedding
good friends with oprah he was totally
in it
he was in rap songs all the time then he
comes out and he runs as a republican
and they say he's literally hitler
because they it's not just about him
they hate you
it's you it's not him it was the best
moment of his 2020 campaign
it was when he tweeted out that picture
and he said they're not coming for me
they're coming for you and i happen to
be in the way
it's not they don't think he's a nazi
they think you're a nazi they don't
think he's a racist they think you're a
racist
they don't think he's gonna destroy the
country and he should be in prison they
think you're going to
destroy the country and probably you
should be in prison
too they have talked about these enemy
lists
they've talked about the truth and
reconciliation commissions re-education
they call you deplorable they call you
irredeemable they call you bitter
clingers that was obama's term
or obama's concept rather you had an
expert one of these geniuses on msnbc
comes out and mentioned that the next
guy is going to be just as bad as trump
he might talk a little better he might
sound a little better
but the gop wants another literally
hitler in 2024
they are not going to be muted we're
going to hear them loudly
uh express that hypocrisy and act on
that hypocrisy
going forward because all they're
looking for now is a slightly more
civilized donald trump
that's why they think things are still
going fine for the party because they
look at the house results they look at
the senate results and say
we're doing fine if we can just get a
donald trump who's not quite so
not quite such a thug not quite so imp
unpalatable to so many people we can
find a more another white grievance
racist
uh sexist all of those things we find
another candidate like that but one
who doesn't have quite the rough edges
we'll be in shape that's what the
republican party is heading for
uh and that what their goal is as they
head towards 2024.
that's that's what they're going for
guaranteed no question
and you have this is uh i don't even
know this guy's name nor do i
particularly care to he's on
msnbc with the msnbc host and with
tim miller who's an ex-republican he was
jeb bush's spokesman
one of the most vile slanderers
in politics right i mean absolutely you
know everybody
who disagrees with him anybody who
disagrees with the liberal left is a
nazi and a white supremacist
you hear this from ex-republicans it's
not just the radical left
it's guys who worked for jeb bush for
goodness sakes this
this sort of thing is going to amp up
and i think we're all going to
we're going to feel a little if we don't
already feel some sympathy or
or empathy for president trump we
certainly will in 2024 when we find out
this wasn't about him
at all and we need to oppose this we
need to fight back against this
not just in this very narrow way of
shrinking
parts of the government or lowering
taxes or something like that
it's a whole blob it's a whole sort of
conspiracy it's not a conspiracy in the
sense that it's not even really
conscious
it's not like three men in a
smoke-filled room saying here's how
we're gonna plot to
destroy the deplorable irredeemable
patriotic americans
it's just this whole edifice which
comprises the universities certainly the
media obviously
hollywood sure even the scientific
establishment which is now saying that
men can become women
based on nothing other than some fetish
ideology
that sort of thing
we have to push back against the whole
edifice
and if we don't do that it's going to
gobble us right up
even there's biden's campaign manager
who's probably going to be his deputy
chief of staff
even she she's her job is to go out
there and sell
joe biden's fake unity healing message
that he's now pretending
to be pushing joe biden a very divisive
figure
who said that mitt romney wanted to
re-enslave black people in america
uh joe biden who just lies and
i mean he's told really awful lies in
his life now he's saying we need unity
and healing and his campaign manager
that's a gen jen o'malley dylan says
uh yeah i want to work with republicans
i'm not saying they're
not a bunch of efforts you know mitch
mcconnell's terrible
but from start to finish biden set out
with this idea that unity was possible
that together we're stronger
that we as a country need healing and
our politics needs that too
yeah yeah efforts yeah you're gonna heal
oh we're gonna make you heal
you're gonna heal whether you like it or
not uh not exactly practicing
what she preaches they never do that
though you'd always see this uh
in on social media or people get letters
about this or even people on tv they say
trump is literally hitler
he's a nazi he's awful we need 70
million nazis in this country
we need to beat them just like we beat
hitler antifa is good i hope antifa
punches all these guys in the face
because love trumps hate huh
hold on it's love trump yeah i love
trump's hate
and the in order to for love to trump
hate we need to kill
all the hateful people i think you've
got a
flaw somewhere in your logic
they're not wishing us well that's for
sure if you're concerned about men's
wellness though you should go to for
hymns.com if you need help with
ed hair loss or if you have a cold if
you are interested in mental health or
covid19 home tests
hymns is here for you through hymns
you can get the prescription medication
that treats ed real science
real solutions to ed you get the same
active ingredient as that expensive
little blue pill
but without the expensive price tag no
embarrassing conversations i know men
exactly don't want to talk about that
sort of thing
but this is a great discreet way to do
it no expensive appointments
just answer a few questions online about
your medical history and a provider will
confidentially review
if approved your medication is shipped
directly to your door in discrete
packaging and shipping
is free try hymns
today by starting out with a free online
visit go to for hymns dot com
slash michael for your free visit that
is for hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com mich ael
prescription products are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online consultation with a medical
provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate
see the website for full details and
safety information remember that is
for hims.com michael
aoc then comes in after after joe
biden's
campaign manager and likely deputy
chief of staff calls republicans a bunch
of
aoc comes in to double down on that but
also
in classic aoc fashion to make it all
about her
so marco rubio came out he said biden
talks about unity and healing but you
want to know what they really think read
how the person he wants
as the next white house deputy chief of
staff called republicans in congress a
bunch of efforts
aoc responds marco rubio
you stood by in total silence when your
gop colleague called a congresswoman
an effing b on the capital steps in
front of press
apparently some congressman insulted aoc
he denied it
and she's a liar so i don't believe her
maybe he did maybe he didn't but i
certainly don't take her at a word
you weren't big enough to speak then and
you don't get to sob now by the way that
is the right word for those who fleece
and scam working families
you got to give the gal credit she makes
every single thing about
her obama was very good at this i hope
that doesn't mean aoc is going to become
president
obama comes he graduates from law school
he's done nothing in his entire life
he's
accomplished nothing in the professional
world in the political world he's just
all he's really done is going through
school
and he writes a book about his absolute
favorite subject
himself then he writes another book
do you know what that book is about give
you a hint it's his favorite subject
himself then he's president you know he
leaves the presidency
and he writes he's now written two books
about himself he then gets a book deal
and he writes a 750 page book
about do you know can you guess
himself all the things he all the
details he left out of the first
600 pages about himself he was able to
fit in to the next 750 pages
that's what aoc does aoc who is
really bad for the country she is a
stain
on american public life she's like a a
festering wound on american public life
ripping up
real issues that america's had also
ripping up completely imaginary issues
that america's had everything is sort of
contemptuous of the country
but she's she's not the only person who
does this
the reason she does it is because it
gives her a lot of attention and there
are some republicans who've done that
too
but you know narcissism is a
occupational hazard of politics
but aoc does it in particular and the
way she does it is focus on all these
grievances everything is about how she
has been wronged
this is a what 30 year old bartender
with absolutely no qualification to be
in congress other than her
age and she gets this great cushy job
and a significant amount of influence
and she's still complaining imagine that
imagine still complaining about that
but it's always about grievance and so
for instance if if biden does become
president
he's now going to appoint a native
american cabinet secretary
representative debbie holland to lead
the department of the interior
okay that's fine i don't know anything
about deb holland maybe she's fine
probably she's not if she's going to be
a biden pick
but that's fine they're not talking
about her qualifications to lead this
department they're not talking about
her experience to lead this department
they're talking about how she's
native american and how this is historic
because you know we've never had native
americans in the government or anything
except that we've actually already had
not just a native american cabinet
secretary
we've had a native american vice
president and we had him as vice
president
91 years ago the 31st vice president of
the united states
1929 to 1933
first person of color to use the popular
phrase and first native american to be
vice president charles curtis under
herbert hoover was a republican
by the way it's not like he was 132nd
native american or something the guy
had membership in a native american
nation the guy looked extremely native
american
he did it if you're interested in that
sort of historic breakthrough
he did it he was the guy who did it
completely written out of history
because the left controls the history
books
and so you're not going to hear about
that guy maybe occasionally on some
conservative
talk show or in a conservative book
you'll hear a mention of it you won't
hear it anywhere else
they did this with pete butterjudge they
just pete butterjudge is going to be the
head of the department of transportation
why
i don't does pete buddha judge know
anything about transportation no
probably not
it doesn't matter it's historic pete
buda judge according to the media he's
the first
openly gay cabinet secretary except he's
not we just had the first openly gay
cabinet secretary his name was rick
grinnell under donald trump
that happened like five minutes ago it's
been completely written out already
that that is a conspiracy not
necessarily a conscious one it's sort of
reflexive i think for the left
that they have their narrative and
they're sticking to it
whether reality backs it up or not the
media certainly aren't going to correct
them
you want to see the kind of hard-hitting
journalism we have so you know the
washington post has been trying to
overthrow the 2016 election since before
it
occurred well now that they think
biden's got it certainly he's in it's
done deal here's the kind of hard
hitting journalism you can expect
from the washington post pete butted
judge is right
airports are romantic
that's the headline that's i'm not
i'm not gonna read this article i see no
reason to read this article it is i did
once get pretty romantic with my tsa
agent going up the right leg it was at
least i felt it was romantic i don't
know if if he felt that way as well
uh historic it was an historic uh
airport security line
uh you're not going to get any kind of
serious journalism here okay and you're
not going to get it on big tech either
kareem abdul-jabbar you know kareem he
was the basketball star
and then he was an airplane which is my
that's really where i enjoyed his his
work
kareem abdul-jabbar is now saying that
big tech should censor conservatives
and even people who aren't woke just
kind of run-of-the-mill liberals
he says they need to do it because the
conservatives are tweeting
irrational and harmful opinions to
millions
and what's funny his reasoning here is
many americans imbue stars with
political and social intelligence they
just don't
have it doesn't help to be surrounded by
flawing people whose job it is to agree
with everything you say
and you know it's irresponsible and then
they've got to be
censored says kareem abdul-jabbar
a basketball player a very famous
basketball player
and guy who was in some movies and
specifically he was saying that jon
voight should be kicked off
big tech and james woods should as well
two of the only outspoken conservatives
in all of hollywood
those guys are going to come after you
too
it is not conspiracy theory thinking
to say that we need to be skeptical of
these established institutions the
government institutions and even the
institutions outside of the government
it's a the only conspiracy theory is
that those institutions are not
political
that that isn't truly a crazy conspiracy
theory
there is a i guess you could use the
word conspiracy it's not really a
conspiracy it's just
an establishment it's an established
standard
across all of these different sectors
all of which
are hell-bent on shutting up
conservatives
making sure we don't have a voice you're
not going to get that unity and healing
assuming joe biden gets it january 20th
you are going to get a vindictive
response revenge
and if conservatives don't prepare for
that now and if we're not prepared to
fight on every
front of that not just the governmental
front but also
in commercial life also in educational
life
also in technology if you're not
prepared to fight on all those fronts
we don't stand a chance speaking of
technology and science on monday
december 21st the historical docu series
apollo 11 what we saw
will be available exclusively at
dailywire.com the docu-series takes a
detailed look at the apollo 11 mission
to land a man
on the moon apollo 11 what we saw is a
fantastic series to watch with your
loved ones
over the christmas break get it for 20
off with code watch
when you become an insider or above
member over at dailywire.com
subscribe that is dailywire.com
subscribe get 20 off your membership
with codewatch
and access all of our new and existing
content
head on over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with the mailbag
i'm always running late on the mailbag
but i will fly through this
and get to as many questions as i can
from jenny i know it's a long shot but
let's pretend that on january 6
the miracle occurs and president trump
gets four more years
what do you think will be the
ramifications of that i believe
president trump has done great things
and deserves four more years
but i fear the violence that will surely
come from the left
do you think assuming this miraculous
intervention takes place
that the country will be better or worse
for it i love all your shows and can't
wait to see what the future holds for
the daily wire take care
thank you very much i think it would be
great if president trump got another
four years and i think it will be bad if
he doesn't
and i understand the argument here
according to some scuttlebutt rumors
gossip columns
this is what the supreme court was
talking about they said they're going to
be riots you know if we give it to trump
i don't know whether that i usually
don't believe gossip that comes out of
the court
because it comes from from staffers who
are if they're leaking the stuff
by definition they're kind of unreliable
but
i i don't buy into this argument that
because the left
is threatening us with violence we
should give them what they want that's
called appeasement that's called
surrender that's called cowardice
i i'm not giving into that at all
i don't care i'm not going to let a
bunch of bullies
destroy my country because i'm afraid of
them no chance if there were any way
that trump could get four more years
legally and not he shouldn't do it
illegally but if there were a legal way
to do it
i would be all for it and i don't care
what kind of temper tant from the left
would had i don't care if they would try
to burn down cities if they tried to
commit crimes
we could arrest them and put them in
prison i i'm i am not going to uh
have some leftist walk into my walk into
my business and say it's a nice pizza
shop you got here
sure would be a shame if something
happened to it no thank you sir not
not a chance from nicholas dear austere
religious podcaster dr michael knowles
thank you for using my title i have been
watching all the daily wire shows for
years now one of the most interesting
discussions i've seen is on pornography
i have a couple questions one is someone
who's struggled with pornography for
most of my life what is the best way to
get away from it
it's had a tremendous negative impact on
my life and i frankly don't know what to
do other than give in
how can we two how can we as
conservatives best advocate for the
removal of porn from mainstream society
sincerely asking for a friend a good way
to put it i think you're asking for a
lot of friends
this is true for a huge number i mean
the vast vast majority of of men in this
country
have struggled with this they always say
what they say what it's 93 have looked
at internet porn and seven percent are
liars
is the line for men i don't know maybe
women are more moral than men but it's a
it's a scourge obviously and it's also
just categorically different
than in the old days when you had to go
to some cd part of town and buy some
pictures or a magazine
now it comes zapped right into your
phone from anywhere it's extraordinarily
high speed you know there's a zillion
different
movies and videos even though pornhub
apparently just kicked off half their
videos
so it's it's a you know probably the
defining
sort of fleshy temptation of the age but
for sure
how can you avoid it well uh it's it's
once you're hooked it's much like any
vice once you're hooked it's harder to
get at it
but like drinking you know it's easier
to control your drinking if you're not
already an
alcoholic if you are an alcoholic it's
gonna be a little harder but look
everybody
deals with various temptations and
addictions and things like that so
one way to do it is there's a catholic
concept and i think
probably other denominations have this
concept too which is the near occasion
of sin
the idea that there's sin you know you
you're looking at the porn or whatever
you're i don't know you're stealing
things or you're covering your
neighbor's ox or whatever the sin is
and uh so that's a sin and of itself
but if you put yourself in a situation
where you are more likely to give in to
that temptation then you are culpable
for
that too the near the near occasion of
sin is something you need to keep
yourself away from
don't don't put yourself in a place
where you could be tempted so some ways
to do that i don't know i mean there are
i was talking to i think it was matt
fradd the catholic podcaster has written
extensively about this
you can you know put different blockers
and things on your computer
you can make sure that you're not you
don't find yourself in situations where
you're looking at the porn a lot
you should go to confession you should
make sure that you try to practice the
other virtues and you should recognize
like any you know if you were going to a
a
you and talking about alcohol you would
you would recognize this too
that you're going to stumble and you
know if let's say you're looking at porn
every day or more than every day even
let's say you're looking at it every day
and then you find yourself you were able
to look at it
i don't know a couple times a week or
something then you're able to look at it
once a week and then you're able to look
at it once a month and you're able
you know that's something i mean that's
progress maybe better to go cold turkey
you know
but i think the comparison here to
alcoholism is important and the
recognition that if you stumble
all sin and fall short of the glory of
god but you got to keep working at it
you know sometimes
occasionally uh people will introduce me
if i'm speaking at a catholic event i'll
say michael's a devout catholic i always
kind of
pull away from that not because i have
any doubts about the catholic faith
but because i prefer the term practicing
catholic because you the idea of
practicing catholic is you're doing it
and you're going to keep on practicing
until you get it right and this is true
outside of
even just a strictly religious realm of
the virtues you're going to keep on
practicing the virtues even put porn
aside for a second
or i'm sure there are a lot of virtues
that we all fall short in and if you
just keep
practicing them you will get better at
them you won't you won't be perfect
because it's a fallen world
but you you actually will get better at
them you can get better
and uh so i would just encourage you in
that encourage means to take heart
from the la from core right so just take
heart
have courage when you stumble get back
up and keep trying again
best of luck i know a lot of people are
struggling with that so
you know pray about it too and just keep
keep
keep the faith and keep working from
father greg how about that i'm a
catholic priest
riding you from the frozen land to the
north known as canada
which i lovingly call america's hat
recently
our premiere declared that churches are
only allowed 30 people regardless of
size while businesses are allowed 50
capacity moreover the restriction on
churches is effective immediately
whereas the restrictions on businesses
don't come into effect till december
25th
here is my question is it time we
reconsider this whole selling of
indulgences thing
perhaps we gave it up too quickly johann
tetzel had some problems with
mismanagement but the underlying
business model strikes me as sound
moreover i've already spoken to several
of my protestant friends
who are warmed to the idea if it means
they could go to church
wouldn't that be the perfect ending to
2020 catholics and protestants coming
together around indulgences
let me know what you think in christ
father greg an excellent point you
raised father
it had not occurred to me but it's an
excellent point frankly
i don't really have much of an issue
with the sale of indulgences generally i
think this is
you know as i suspect you know as well
this is a very misrepresented
topic and a very very exaggerated topic
and i don't think that uh i think
indulge
indulgences obviously or still exist as
they should
and i i think giving alms is a very good
thing and i think those things go well
together
uh but beyond that even just from a
purely political standpoint
it would be delightful it would be
it would be one of the the wonderful
joyous turns of providence
if the sale of indulgences could bring
the catholic and protestant uh
protestants back together because in our
day
and age the the secular religion that we
all have the secular religion of
liberalism
understands that only commerce is uh
the protected activity that's the
liturgy that we have to protect
all these silly things like going to
church you know or going to synagogue
that that's crazy you don't need to do
any of that you just got to go buy more
stuff well okay
two can play at that game very very wise
idea father greg
from tyler i'll do one more i am a 16
year old canadian boy lots of canadians
today
and i need your advice in a situation
that is happening in my life at the
moment
at my school i am openly conservative i
have worn my red trump hat to school
many times
i was notified by the vice principal
that my hat offended a student
so our school was not a safe space
anymore oh my gosh
man i'm so glad i'm not a kid and it
would be it was crazy enough when i was
a kid but now good goodness gracious
since i was not allowed to wear my red
maga hat
i went onto amazon and bought a black
mag ahead because i wanted to continue
to express my conservative opinion
and have meaningful discussions about
politics with my peers
i had my black maga hat taken away
because it was also offensive
when i retrieved it at the end of the
day i was told that i would be suspended
if i wore another trump hat or anything
like that to school again
i asked why my political speech was not
allowed but the gay pride flag was and
she said that i am not a marginalized
group i'm a straight white male oh
you're
you're the worst you're the oppressor
she said that the lgbt groups were not
political ah there it is
but they are only supporting equal
rights for marginalized people i want to
continue to be openly conservative but i
do not want to be suspended what should
i do
well you're in a tricky spot because
your your school administrator is
obviously
extremely stupid and ignorant and
and doesn't even understand the words
that are coming out of her mouth
so when she says
this political symbol is not political
because it's only about
equality and rights so
one one response you could have is i'm
pretty sure equality and rights
are political subjects i think this is
written about
in the declaration of independence for
instance all men are created equal and
they're
endowed by the creator with certain
unalienable rights that's obviously a
political
sort of statement but but what it comes
from is this
this very narrow understanding of
politics which the left
and the right have both acquiesced to
both really the right the left forced it
on us
and the right acquiesced and agreed to
it which is
what politics means most basically is
public life how we all get along
together that's what aristotle's talking
about in aristotle's politics
you know wrote a whole book on the
subject and this is how we've understood
politics for most of our
civilization's history then
in recent years and really you see this
ramp up during the 60s
the left comes in and says everything is
political now
so it used to be you know you had public
life and that was all political but
you know the way that you lived with
your family
that was sort of private or the way that
you the
nike shoes the sneakers that you bought
were those were private choices that's
not a political choice right it doesn't
really affect anything
the nike comes in recently it makes it a
very political choice but everything
became political the kind of coffee you
drink becomes political
the kind of movies you go see become
political
everything becomes political in the
sense of partisan ideological
your relationship to your wife becomes
very political i mean the
feminists in the 70s said the personal
is the political but the irony of this
was
that the political life became
de-politicized
all the things that you really should be
able to debate the definition of
marriage
the laws that we have surrounding
abortion you know killing babies
all these sorts of things the death
penalty
they were taken out of politics so we
could no longer debate those
things we just had experts tell us what
to do
whether you're going to wear a mask all
the time and cover your face up for over
a year in public
that became not no longer is that a
political question
and the right really led by libertarians
acquiesced to this they said yeah that's
true
we just have to shrink the government
not let the government do anything
and the government now is going to be
what we talk about instead of politics
more broadly
and that's that's going to be that
look at the effect of this i think you
need to tell your teacher or
administrator or whatever
that politics is much bigger than this
that you are you are by definition a
marginalized group because you're
expressing a political opinion
that is quite mainstream right so
mainstream that
the originator of that opinion is the
president of the united states
that you're you're expressing that
opinion and you're being threatened with
suspension and you're the most
marginalized group
in the entire school she'll still
probably suspend you because
that's the political regime that we're
living in now and canada is to the left
of america
you can at least make your case you
might get suspended though
it might force you not to wear the hat
and as long as you're a student
you're going to have to deal with that i
mean that that's the sort of prudential
and practical reality of it
but i think if in the meantime you could
teach your teacher something
that would be very helpful you know
we've had a big debate over whether jill
biden's a doctor or not
because she has this kind of
administrative credential from a
university that has a building named
after her husband and
you know is she really a doctor well
she's not a phd and she's not an md and
she and i've said you know doctors are
people who teach people so you you can
be
a doctor my young doctor friend in
canada please
teach your teacher we'll all have a lot
of teaching to do and unfortunately it
sounds like the left does not want to
listen
but we can all listen to one another
again on monday in the meantime i'm
michael knows this the michael knowles
show see you then
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there